so I know it's warm in here and we just
had a huge turkey lunch but that doesn't
mean we can lose focus on how important
our annual recap and planning meeting is
it is the only meeting we celebrate with
a turkey lunch exactly so let's all pay
attention now 47 weeks I can do it
just get up and leave can be in Costa
Rica by morning on the beach with a
mamacita on each arm dangos mamacita's
give me every time but Who am I kidding
I can't leave these people need me
I love meetings the structure the notes
smell everyone's here
no one's on Facebook and plenty of
opportunities to raise my hand then it's
Ana time I wonder what the woman I'm
gonna marry is doing right now she's
probably at work or maybe she's
showering no Elliot you haven't earned
that yet she is a lady and you will
respect her I'm sorry I yelled at you
this mole knew that could it be melanoma
am I too young to worry about my legacy
or am I too old what do i define the
meaning of my life bye except Kaylin oh
[ __ ] what was she saying do I not and
say yes now but what if she said
something racist I can't fall for that
again I stay calm but the whole crowd
grows so loud he opens his mouth but the
words won't come out he's choking how
everybody's joking now the clocks run
out times up over bloah I really think
we should focus on our legacy I mean
nowadays everybody want to talk like
they got something to say but nothing
comes out when they move you did it
Natalie you had no idea what you were
talking about but no one noticed you
faked it
made it it no faked it till you mate I
don't think any of these are words huh
good meeting oh yeah who wants leftovers
you